un an après la situation est
catastrophique je pense j ai tellement
mon salaire voire 60 à 65 dollars par
mois alors que avant la crise ils
étaient entre 800 et 900 donc on fait ce
qu'il faut mais à la fin on a juste quoi
survivre à la bête est prof est propre
ce sera là le doigt dans la power stage
mais ailleurs mains sales in barça me
dès maintenant demander n'importe quel
libanais
dis-lui comment tuer voir personne
indiquée je suis bien je suis obligé de
continuer à vivre pour financer
au final six ans
sur many people
[Musique]
cette explosion n'a pas seulement été
une explosion juste matériel mais elle a
détruit des vies du pipeau diary mme
alexandra
[Musique]
un double menton